Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, der Gesprächsserie über Raumfahrt von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 27. Ausgabe in unserer langen Reihe. Und heute soll es gehen über eine Mission am Boden, die aber sich eigentlich in ganz ferne Weiten erstreckt. Eine Simulationsmission, ein Flug zum Mars. Und um darüber mal Auskunft zu erhalten, was es damit in Aufsicht hat und wie dieses Projekt voranschreitet, habe ich mich abermals an das ASTEC begeben, die Niederlassung der ESA in den Niederlanden. Und begrüße als Gesprächspartnerin Jennifer Noan. Du bist hier unter dem Titel Exploration Life Scientist. Das klingt toll. Was versteht man darunter?
Unsere Abteilung beschäftigt sich damit, Langzeitflüge ins Weltall vorzubereiten. Das bedeutet, dass wir uns Gedanken darüber machen, wie man die Nebenwirkung, die so ein langer Flug haben würde, reduzieren kann oder sogar möglicherweise ganz vermeiden kann. Das heißt, die Schwerelosigkeit hat auf dem menschlichen Körper gewisse Auswirkungen. Die wollen wir versuchen zu bekämpfen. Darüber machen wir viel Forschung. Wenn man sich auf eine solch lange Reise begibt, ist man ziemlich lange isoliert und eingeengt. Das hat Auswirkungen auf die Psyche von den Menschen, die in einem Raumschiff sitzen. Das beforschen wir. Dann gibt es natürlich auch noch das große Risiko der Weltraumstrahlung. Auch da haben wir einige Projekte zu laufen. Damit beschäftigen wir uns im Groben in unserer Abteilung.
So heißt auch dann die ganze Abteilung. Life Sciences. Darum geht es. Man setzt sich explizit um all das aus, was sich jetzt explizit auf Menschen im Weltall bezieht. Bevor wir vielleicht noch mal genauer zu der Tätigkeit der Gruppe kommen und auch dann natürlich auch noch mal genauer auf die Details von Mars500, wenn mich jetzt mal interessieren, was so dein Weg in die Raumfahrt gewesen ist. Bist du da auch schon früh in den Topf gefallen und gesagt, das und nichts anderes?
Ich war schon immer interessiert, dran Astronautin zu werden. Ich dachte aber immer, das ist ziemlich schwer, Astronautin zu werden. Dann wollte ich immer Pilotin werden. Allerdings haben mir da meine Augen an den Streich gespielt. Ich sehe leider zu schlecht. Dann habe ich beschlossen, naja, dann lerne ich halt was Anständiges und habe Medizin studiert. Hab dann aber gelernt oder musste dann eben sehen, dass mir die Medizin selber nicht so arg viel Spaß macht und habe beschlossen, dass ich in die Forschung gehe. Hab danach noch Neurowissenschaften studiert und unter dem oder mit dem Hintergrund habe ich mich dann auf eine Stelle hier bei der Europäischen Raumfahrt-Agentur beworben und das hat geklappt. Und jetzt bin ich schon seit fünf Jahren hier und bin eben, wie gesagt, als Exploration Life Scientist tätig.
Also wieder so eine interessante Kombination, wo man so auf der einen Seite eine Ausbildung macht, die jetzt nicht unmittelbar in die Raumfahrt weist, aber dann in der Kombination mit den anderen Disziplinen und eben auch so mit dem eigenen Grundinteresse an der Raumfahrt sich dann hier ganz gut kombinieren lässt.
Genau, also ich bin ganz froh, dass ich beide Studiengänge absolviert habe. Das hilft mir im Verständnis von den Experimenten, die wir eben vorbereiten und auch durchführen, das hilft mir im Verständnis und in der Kommunikation mit den Wissenschaftlern, mit denen wir zusammenarbeiten. Also ich habe es nicht umsonst studiert, auch wenn ich aktiv beide Studienfächer jetzt nicht mehr so gebrauche.
Ja, gilt das dann auch so für die anderen Teammitglieder? Ist das also grundsätzlich die Ausrichtung oder ist das dann auch interdisziplinär noch bestückt?
In unserer Abteilung haben wir eigentlich alle Medizin studiert. Das ist wichtig, um eben zu verstehen, was wir hier beforschen und zusätzlich haben ein paar Leute auch Biologie studiert. Also wir sind oder ich bin jetzt nicht speziell.
Das Thema Weltraummedizin ist ja hier auch schon mal zu Sprache gekommen, vor einigen Ausgaben RZ021. Lautet da die Nummer für die Sendung Weltraummedizin mit Robert Gerzer. Da haben wir viele Aspekte besprochen, wie insbesondere die Schwerelosigkeit den Astronauten zu schaffen macht. Und auch in der Ausgabe zum Parabelflug gab es da auch interessante Einblicke in diese Richtung. Aber hier geht es ja vor allem so um die Langzeitplanung auch. Also gar nicht so sehr nur jetzt um die Erforschung, was passiert da medizinisch. Sondern auch, wie kann man dem konkret entgegenwirken, welche Maßnahmen kann und muss man ergreifen, um solche längeren Missionen dann auch wirklich durchführbar machen. Verstehe ich das richtig?
Genau. Also wir wissen, dass es technisch sehr herausfordernd und sehr schwierig sein wird, um zum Beispiel eine Mission mit einer Mannschaft von zum Beispiel sechs Leuten erfolgreich zum Mars zu bringen und auch wieder zurück. Also wir wissen, dass es technisch schwierig wird. Wir wissen aber auch, dass wir uns um die Menschen selber kümmern müssen, die dann in dem Raumschiff sitzen. Und darum geht es eben unter anderem in Mars500. Und darum geht es eigentlich auch immer bei unserer Arbeit hier.
Jetzt gab es ja schon lange Aufenthalte im Weltall. Das ist ja in dem Sinne nichts Neues, sondern auf der Raumstation haben ja einige sehr lange ausgehalten über ein Jahr. Reicht das nicht auch aus, um das zu studieren? Oder ist jetzt für solche langen Flüge, ist da jetzt noch mal irgendwas grundlegend anders?
Das Mars500-Projekt wurde konzipiert, um genau eine Mission zu Mars zu simulieren. Es stimmt, dass schon einige Leute relativ lange auf der Raumstation waren, auf der internationalen. Und auch auf der Mir-Station gab es einige Russen, die relativ lange dort waren. Aber der Unterschied zu der Mission, die wir jetzt durchgeführt haben oder noch durchführen, ist, dass die Astronauten, die bisher sehr lange auf der ISS oder auf der Mir-Station waren, immer wieder von Versorgungsflügen Versorgung bekommen haben. Die haben frisches Essen bekommen, die haben neue Klamotten bekommen, die haben neue Geräte bekommen für Experimente zum Beispiel. Die wurden sozusagen besucht von anderen Astronauten und hatten dadurch ein bisschen Abwechslung in ihrem langen und eintönigen Aufenthalt oben auf der Station. Die Raumfahrer, die sich zum Mars begeben in der Zukunft oder auch unsere Mars-Aunaten, wie wir sie gerne nennen, haben dieses Privileg nicht. Die werden anderthalb Jahre oder vielleicht auch länger in ihrem Raumschiff eingesperrt sein. Die werden immer dieselben Leute sehen. Die werden von denselben Gütern leben müssen, die schon am Anfang in das Raumschiff geladen wurden. Die bekommen also nicht nach einem Jahr oder nach einem halben Jahr frische Sachen, sei es Essen, sei es Klamotten, sei es irgendwelche Überraschungen oder Geschenke. Das ist ein großer Unterschied zu den Astronauten, die eben schon lange auf der ISS oder mir Station waren.
Und man kann ja auch nicht wieder zurück. Also ich meine auf der ISS, wenn man jetzt sagt, ich habe keine Lust mehr, oder anders formuliert, wenn sich ein Umstand ergibt, der jetzt eine unmittelbare Rückkehr erfordert, wie zum Beispiel medizinischer Notfall, kann ja durchaus sein, gab es glaube ich in dem Sinne noch gar nicht, aber könnte natürlich jederzeit passieren. Dann ist da eine Kapsel an Bord, da steigt man dann rein, drückt auf den Knopf und schon ist man wieder in der Heimat, jetzt mal etwas salopp formuliert. Das fällt natürlich bei so einer Langzeitmission weg. Was ist denn so mit Flügen zum Mond? Das ist vielleicht nicht dieselbe Distanz, aber auch da hat man auch glaube ich ähnliche Aspekte gehabt, oder?
Das ist sehr vergleichbar, bloß ist der Mond eben sehr viel näher. Die Apollo-Missionen waren alle unter drei Wochen in der Länge. Wenn wir wirklich zu Mars gehen wollen oder zu einem anderen Planeten und dahin zieht es uns gerade, weil wir wollen noch weiter, der Mensch wurde oder die Menschheit wollte schon immer noch weiter gehen, als man bisher gegangen ist, dann müssen wir uns eben darauf einstellen, dass wir mehr als anderthalb Jahre unterwegs sind, inklusive Rückflug. Und das stellt uns vor viele Herausforderungen.
Also das ist auch länger als der längste Aufenthalt, liegt bei 437 Tagen oder so. Also auch ein Marsflug ist schon aus den technischen Notwendigkeiten her länger als alles das, was man bisher gemacht hat. Das stimmt. Wenn man jetzt so eine, also was war denn jetzt eigentlich das Ziel? Also um vielleicht mal kurz anzuschneiden, Mars500 ist ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt von ESA und Roskosmos, der russischen Raumfahrtagentur. Das ist jetzt auch nichts, also insofern nichts Neues. Also es gab es gab ähnliche Sachen schon mal vorher. Also solche Langzeitstudien sind schon vorher schon mal gemacht worden, vor einigen Jahren. Die waren aber nicht so lang.
Genau, es gab schon viele Isolationsstudien unter der Leitung von den Russen. Wir Europäer haben auch schon ein paar Isolationsstudien durchgeführt, aber wir haben eben noch nie konkret einen Flug zum Mars simuliert. Deswegen ist das Mars500-Projekt bisher ein Unikat.
Und Mars500 heißt das deshalb, weil man über einen Daumen 500 Tage lang diese Teilnehmer an der Isolation aussetzt. Also es sind tatsächlich ein paar mehr, 520 Tage sind es, glaube ich. Also wie geht man da ran? Also was mich erstmal interessieren würde, ist, wie kam es jetzt eigentlich dazu? Ich meine, okay, Pläne zum Mars zu fliegen, gab es schon immer. Das ist so ein Menschheitstraum. Und das ist ja aber jetzt noch nicht konkret. Es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man sagt, okay, in zehn Jahren müssen wir jetzt irgendwie hin, weil jetzt haben wir ja die konkreten Pläne und das Geld liegt schon da. Sondern das kann halt bald mal vielleicht irgendwann mal losgehen. Aber so wann genau, weiß man nicht. Aber man hat jetzt schon das Gefühl, man müsste sich jetzt schon rüsten, um die technische Machbarkeit überhaupt auszuloten. An welchem Zeitpunkt kam es denn dann dazu, dass man sagt, okay, jetzt müssen wir auch diese Simulation durchführen?
Die Idee von Mars500 wurde vor beinahe zehn Jahren geboren. Wir haben ja 1999 die letzte große Isolationsstudie mit den Russen durchgeführt. Damals haben wir einen Aufenthalt auf der ISS simuliert mit mehreren Besucherflügen oder verschiedene Besucher-Crews, die die Hauptcrew auf der ISS besucht hat. Und damals dachte man sich eben, der nächste Schritt ist jetzt eine Mission zu Mars zu simulieren. Und deswegen kam es eben zu Mars500. Wir haben uns für 520 Tage entschieden, weil mit den heutigen Technologien wäre es so, dass man tatsächlich 240 Tage zu Mars bräuchte und dann nochmal 250 für den Weg zurück. Und zusätzlich dazu haben wir eben noch einen Aufenthalt von 30 Tagen auf dem Mars eingebaut.
Ah, ok, das heißt der eigentliche Flug sind nur 490 plus einen Monat Urlaub auf dem Mars sozusagen. Na wenn man so lange fliegt, dann will man natürlich auch ein bisschen was davon haben. Und ist das jetzt so eine, wenn man das jetzt 99 schon mal gemacht hat für die ISS, hat man denn damals auch die Erfahrung gemacht, dass so eine Simulation wirklich später auch konkret verwertbare Ergebnisse bringt? Was ist denn da beispielsweise festgestellt worden? Was sich dann auch später in der ISS so in irgendeiner Form wieder gefunden hat?
Das Hauptergebnis von der Studie von 1999, der sogenannten Sphinx-Studie, war, dass es sehr wichtig ist, dass man die kulturellen Unterschiede der verschiedenen Astronauten, nenne ich sie jetzt mal, in Betracht zieht. Es kam zu Streitereien während dieser Mission. Diese Streitereien lagen jetzt aber nicht unbedingt darin oder daran, dass wir die falschen Leute zusammen gesetzt haben, sondern es lag daran, dass die Astronauten bestimmte Gesten und bestimmte Aussagen missverstanden haben. Und es lag eben daran, dass westliche Astronauten die Gesten und Gepflogenheiten der russischen Astronauten missverstanden haben. Dadurch kam es zu Streitereien.
Also wir reden jetzt von einfachen Handbewegungen im Prinzip. Daumen hoch, Daumen runter. Nein, ganz so banal. Oder die generelle Ausdrucke in der Sprache.
Ganz so banal war es nicht. Also es ging eben darum, dass in der Silvesternacht oder um Mitternacht dann Küsschen verteilt wurden. Und es wurde eben von einigen Astronauten oder von den Isolationsmitgliedern, Teilnehmern missverstanden. Und es kam dann auch zu Handgreiflichkeiten, weil sich dann zwei Grüppchen gebildet haben, die sich gegenseitig dann eben in Schutz genommen haben. Und die Hauptlektion von dieser Sphinx-Studie war dann eben, dass wir zukünftig Astronauten oder zukünftig Isolationsteilnehmer darüber belehren müssen, wie verschiedene Kulturen miteinander umgehen, wie verschiedene Kulturen bestimmte Umgangsformen miteinander pflegen.
Interessant, also gar nicht so das, was man jetzt zunächst einmal denken würde, dass es vor allem psychologische, medizinische Probleme sind, sind eigentlich eher die kulturellen Aspekte erstmal das Hauptproblem gewesen.
Das war auch eine Überraschung für uns. Natürlich hat dieser Streit dann auch oder dieser Konflikt hat dann auch zu psychologischen Problemen geführt, nicht bei einzelnen Mitgliedern, sondern die Gruppen. Die Dynamik wurde dann eben etwas gestört, was dann ganz interessant war zu beobachten. Und es war dann auch interessant zu sehen, was man von außen dagegen machen kann. Und es gab natürlich in dieser Studie auch medizinische Erkenntnisse. Aber der Hauptauslöser für viele Nachfolgestudien war eben dieser Konflikt wegen den verschiedenen Kulturen.
Das heißt, so ein Simulationsprojekt beginnt nicht erst in dem Moment, wo man jetzt alle einsperrt, sondern eigentlich schon sehr viel früher. Es ist quasi das Training, die Vorbereitung, die Vermeidung von Konflikten, das steht zunächst einmal im Mittelpunkt. Man muss quasi schon mal den richtigen Ansatz finden, weil später kann man es dann eben nicht mehr korrigieren. Und nachdem man sich jetzt klar war, dass man das eben über diese massive Zeit hin tun möchte, wie geht man dann ran? Also das Ganze findet ja in Russland statt, auf dem Roskosmos-Gelände nehme ich an, ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Wir arbeiten mit dem Institut für Biomedizinische Probleme zusammen, dem IBMP, und die sitzen in Moskau.
Und wie tritt man das dann los? Also womit fängt man an? Also man braucht ja einen Ort, aber man braucht natürlich auch Teilnehmer. Wie entwickelt sich so ein Projekt?
Wir haben natürlich erstmal grob geplant, wie diese Mission ablaufen soll. Nachdem dann der grobe Zeitplan stand, haben wir begonnen, nach Freiwilligen zu suchen, die bei dieser Studie eben mitmachen wollten. Die Mannschaft besteht aus sechs Leuten. Vier davon sind Russen und zwei davon sind Europäer. Das heißt, wir Europäer oder wir von der ESA mussten dann erst mal zwei Freiwillige finden, zwei Fähige und das hat gut und gerne schon mal ein Jahr gebraucht, um die dann schließlich auszusuchen.
Wie hat man die gefunden?
Wir hatten einen öffentlichen Aufruf, auf den sich alle Europäer bewerten durften. Wir haben mehr als 5.500 Bewerbungen bekommen.
5.500?
Die sind wir dann natürlich alle durchgegangen. Dann haben wir diejenigen, die in die nähere Auswahl kamen, persönlich angerufen, haben mit ihnen noch mal besprochen, ob sie verstehen, um was es im Mars500 geht, ob sie überhaupt Zeit haben, wie sie das mit ihrer Arbeit, mit ihrer Familie in Einklang bringen würden, sollten sie ausgewählten.
Wir reden ja davon, ein 1,5 Jahr komplett weg zu sein.
Naja, noch ein bisschen mehr, weil die Leute mussten ja eben auch trainiert werden und auch nach der Studie oder nach der Isolation müssen sie uns noch ein bisschen zur Verfügung stehen.
Also im Prinzip zwei Jahre so im Groben. Wie viel blieben da noch übrig, nachdem man das noch mal klar gemacht hat?
Wir hatten dann noch mal ungefähr 150 Leute übrig. Dann haben wir von den 150, die noch übrig waren, haben wir medizinische Tests durchgeführt. Die mussten natürlich kerngesund sein und mussten das auch nachweisen können. Und dann ist noch gut die Hälfte übrig geblieben. Die haben wir dann eingeladen zu persönlichen Gesprächen und auch persönlichen Untersuchungen noch mal. Die wurden dann noch mal in Köln am europäischen Astronautenzentrum auf Herz und Nieren überprüft. Die haben mit einem Psychologen gesprochen, die haben einen psychologischen Test durchgeführt und haben sich ganz am Ende dann noch mal einem Interview-Board gestellt, das aus sechs Leuten bestand.
Kommen wir mal zu den medizinischen Voraussetzungen. Ich meine, dass die jetzt nicht krank sein dürfen, ist klar. Aber heißt das, dass man auch dieselben Anforderungen an sie gestellt hat, wie man sie jetzt an normale Astronauten für eine richtige Mission auch gestellt hätte? Also auch dieselbe körperliche Fitness?
Wir haben eigentlich die körperlichen Bedingungen oder die medizinischen Bedingungen, die von Astronauten verlangt werden, in Mars500 übernommen. Das heißt, ja, sie mussten körperlich fit sein.
Obwohl ja die Anforderungen ganz andere sind. Also man hat ja nicht Schwerelosigkeit etc.
Genau, aber wir wollten natürlich alles so real simulieren wie möglich und dazu hat eben auch gehört, dass wir Leute auswählen, die es durchaus auch zu einem Astronaut geschafft hätten.
Ahja, das heißt, die, die daran teilnehmen, die können sich zumindest rühmen, so eine Astronautenauswahl schon mal bestanden zu haben, auch wenn sie danach nicht unbedingt eine Astronautenkarriere anstreben würden. Vielleicht ja immer noch können. Und was hat sich so herausgestellt, was die Motivation dieser Leute ist, daran teilzunehmen? Weil ich meine, wenn jetzt bei mir einer an die Tür klopfen würde, dann würde hier nicht mal zwei Jahre eingesperrt werden, würde ich mir ja auch denken, so geht's noch.
Eigentlich alle, die sich bei uns beworben haben, haben angegeben, dass sie sich für Raumfahrt interessieren, dass sie schon immer Astronauten werden wollten, dass sie den bemannten Raumflug und die bemannte Raumfahrt unterstützen und dazu beitragen wollen, zum Beispiel eine Mission zum Mars zu verwirklichen. Alle sind abenteuerlustig gewesen, alle waren oder sind noch sehr neugierig, sehr aufgeschlossen für Neues und sind natürlich auch offen für Herausforderungen, wie zum Beispiel eine Mars-Mission.
Aber können Sie jetzt nicht unbedingt Hoffnung machen, sich dann auch später wirklich auf eine Mars-Mission zu bewerben, weil das noch so weit in der Zukunft liegt, dass sie dann wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr geeignet sind?
Unsere Mars500-Mannschaft, die jetzt gerade bei der Mission oder bei unserer Simulation mitmacht, wäre ideal für eine Mission zu Mars. Ich bezweifle allerdings, dass die mitmachen oder dass wir sie wirklich mal zu Mars schicken, weil der echte Flug zu Mars noch zu weit weg liegt.
Das heißt, man hat jetzt 6 Leute ausgewählt, aber es sind alles Männer, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Genau, es sind alles Männer.
Gibt es einen Grund, oder ist das nur so passiert?
Wir wollten eigentlich idealerweise eine Besatzung zusammenstellen aus 3 Frauen und 3 Männern. Haben aber leider aus medizinischen Gründen keine 3 Frauen gefunden. Die Frauen, die sich beworben hatten, waren alle sehr fähig und hätten auch ganz gut gepasst. Aber wie gesagt, aus verschiedenen medizinischen Gründen hat es dann eben leider nicht geklappt. Das Mars500-Projekt besteht ja aus 2 Studien. Die 105-Tage-Studie fand vor 3 Jahren schon statt. Und bei dieser 105-Tage-Studie war tatsächlich eine Frau Reservistin für Mars500. Die hat es zwar nicht in die Hauptbesatzung geschafft, aber wäre einer von der Hauptmannschaft ausgefallen, wäre die eingesprungen. Also es gibt schon fähige Frauen.
Ja, das wollte ich auch gar nicht bezweifeln. Ich frage mich halt nur, ob es jetzt einen besonderen Grund hat. Aber ist natürlich klar, wenn man jetzt niemanden findet, der auch wirklich die Anforderungen erfüllt, dann kann man das nicht ändern. Okay, also es gab im Prinzip 2 Teile. Mars500 besteht aus einem Mars100 und einem Mars500. Warum hat man das noch mal gemacht? Wollte man erst mal gucken, ob man so richtig liegt, bevor man die Vollstrecke geht?
Genau, die 105-Tages-Studie, die wir vor 3 Jahren durchgeführt haben, war eine Mini-Mars520-Tages-Studie. Wir haben da dieselben Experimente und denselben Ablauf gehabt, wie jetzt in der großen Studie. Wir wollten aber nochmal testen, in realiter, ob das wissenschaftliche Programm so durchführbar ist, wie wir es jetzt eben haben. Außerdem waren die Module, in denen sich die Mars500-Mannschaft jetzt befindet, zum damaligen Zeitpunkt ganz neu renoviert. Und wir wollten einfach testen, ob auch alles funktioniert.
Genau, kommen wir nochmal darauf, wo das eigentlich stattfindet. In Moskau hatten wir schon, aber man versucht ja, so nah an einer möglichen Realität zu sein, wie irgendwie möglich. Das hat sich ja jetzt schon abgezeichnet. Dazu gehört eben auch dieser Ort. Das heißt, man simuliert ein Raumschiff, was eben konkret den Weg zum Mars antritt. Aber wenn man sich da noch 30 Tage auf dem Mars aufhält, muss man eigentlich den Mars auch noch dazu simulieren.
Genau, also was wir gemacht haben ist, wir haben vier Module zur Verfügung für diesen Flug zum Mars. Wir haben sogar fünf Module, wovon eigentlich nur vier gebraucht werden. Und das fünfte eben das Mars-Modul ist, das wir nur in der Mitte der Mission gebrauchen. Die anderen vier Module sind zum einen ein Forschungsmodul, wo die ganzen wissenschaftlichen Experimente durchgeführt werden, wo einfache medizinische Eingriffe vorgenommen werden können, sollte sich zum Beispiel einer der Astronauten, sich zum Beispiel ein Bein oder ein Arm brechen, könnte der dort versorgt werden. Dann haben wir ein großes Vorratsmodul, wo das Essen gelagert wird, wo Kleidung gelagert wird und auch Gerätschaften für verschiedene wissenschaftliche Experimente. Dann haben wir das Modul, in dem die Crew eigentlich lebt sozusagen. Da befindet sich eine Küche drin, ein Wohnzimmer und die einzelnen Kabinen für jedes Crew-Mitglied. Und dann haben wir noch das Mars-Landemodul, in dem sich die eine Hälfte der Crew befindet, während die andere eben auf dem Mars versucht, durchführt.
Okay, also ist das wirklich so eingerichtet, wie man das so heute meint, wie man so eine Mars-Mission durchführen würde? Die Dinge sind ja anders, also man hat ja keine Schwerelosigkeit, die Dinge fliegen jetzt nicht so herum, man hat quasi die Gravitation als Nebeneffekt, die man jetzt nicht rausrechnen kann. Also es ist schon anders, oder?
Bei einem echten Flug zu Mars würde die Crew dadurch, dass sie eben schwerelos ist, den ganzen Raum des Raumschiffs benutzen können. Das heißt, für die gibt es kein Oben und Unten, es gibt für sie keine Decke und kein Boden. Die können einfach alles benutzen. Hier auf der Erde können wir das eben leider nicht, deswegen sind die Module, die wir haben, etwas größer. Die leben auf einer Oberfläche von ungefähr 200 Quadratmetern. Und wenn man das jetzt extra poliert auf ein echtes Raumschiff, ist der Platz, der unseren Mars-Teilnehmern gerade zur Verfügung steht, vergleichbar mit dem Platz, den sie in einem Raumschiff hätten, in dem sie eben alles nutzen könnten.
Aber jetzt auch so vom Handling her hat man jetzt nicht versucht, da Schwerelosigkeit noch sich so auszudenken, dass irgendwie die Dinge an Fäden herbeigeflogen kommen oder so, sondern es ist halt einfach so, wie es bei uns ist.
Genau, zum großen Teil ist es so wie bei uns. Der Hauptschwerpunkt von Mars500 ist ja die Psychologie der Teilnehmer. Und ja, da liegt eben unser Schwerpunkt drauf, weswegen wir jetzt nicht noch Elemente eingeführt haben, mit denen wir Schwerelosigkeit simulieren können. Wir haben eine Zeit lang überlegt, kurz vor der Landung auf dem Mars eine sogenannte Bettruhphase einzuführen, indem die drei Probanden, die dann eben später auf dem Mars landen, sich für bis zu zwei Wochen ins Bett legen, mit dem Kopf etwas nach unten geneigt, um dadurch eben die Effekte der Schwerelosigkeit zu simulieren und sie dann eben mit diesen Nebenwirkungen auf den Mars zu lassen. Aber wir haben uns gedacht, wir wollen eben vor allem nach der Psychologie gucken, nach den Veränderungen, auf die einzelnen Mitglieder, aber auch auf die ganze Gruppe und deswegen haben wir dann beschlossen, dass wir das Element der Schwerelosigkeit erstmal weglassen. Die Schwerelosigkeit beforschen wir auf anderen Plattformen, wie zum Beispiel in den richtigen Bettruhestudien.
Also Kopf nach unten zwei Wochen lang klingt ja schon ein bisschen nach Folter. Was hätte das jetzt für Effekte, was könnte dadurch simuliert werden?
In Bettruhestudien wird es eben so gemacht, dass sich Probanden bis zu 90 Tage ins Bett legen, mit dem Kopf etwas nach unten geneigt. Das sind 6 Grad, mit denen die Probanden dann eben nach unten liegen. Und dadurch wird der Effekt der Schwerelosigkeit simuliert. Und zwar wenn ein Astronaut sich oder wenn sich ein Mensch in einer Schwerelosigkeit befindet, kommt es zu einer Umverteilung des Blutvolumens. Es kommt dazu, dass sich mehr Blut im Kopf ansammelt und relativ viel Blut aus den Beinen in die oberen Körperregionen strömt. Und das wird eben in den sogenannten Bettruhstudien simuliert oder eben nachgemacht. Und diese Umverteilung des Blutes und auch, dass man die Muskeln nicht benutzt, sind eben Effekte, die in der Schwerelosigkeit passieren und vorkommen. Und diese Effekte werden dann in Bettruhstudien beforscht. Und es gibt auch Tests, die dieser Blutumverteilung entgegenwirken.
Richtige Astronauten müssen ja dann auch viel Sport treiben. Das gehört ja dann eigentlich zum festen Tagesprogramm. Das heißt, würde man jetzt wirklich zum Mars fliegen, wäre man wahrscheinlich, nicht ein Großteil des Tages, aber doch ein signifikantes Teil des Tages, im Prinzip die ganze Zeit beim Fahrrad fahren. Und beim Benutzen anderer Instrumente, sind die denn auch Teil der Simulation?
Und so Mars500-Jungs müssen oder dürfen zwei Stunden am Tag Übungen machen. Das bedeutet, die radeln eben auf einem Fahrrad oder laufen auf dem Laufband und halten sich fit. Die haben auch ein Rudergerät an Bord, mit dem sie sich fit halten. Aber es ist verpflichtend für die, dass sie mindestens zwei Stunden am Tag Sport machen.
Ich meine, die sind ja auch beengst da. Wenn man jetzt mal die Schwerelosigkeit rausdenkt, also allein in seinem eigenen Haus die ganze Zeit zu sitzen und sich nicht zu bewegen, führt ja eigentlich auch schon so zum körperlichen Verfall. Von daher ist das wahrscheinlich eh sinnvoll. Aber auch für die Psychologie, oder?
Ja, also es tut ihnen sehr gut, Sport zu machen. Wir sind ja in regelmäßigen Kontakt mit denen und die berichten eigentlich immer wieder, dass es ihnen sehr gut tut, Sport zu machen, um den Kopf frei zu bekommen und um so was Normales, wie sie es in ihrem normalen Leben eben machen, durchzuführen. Und sie freuen sich eigentlich jeden Tag auf ihre zwei Stunden Sport.
Diese wissenschaftlichen Experimente, die da jetzt gemacht werden, sind ja nicht wirklich Experimente in Schwerelosigkeit, zwangsläufig, sind es dann trotzdem sinnvolle Experimente, die dort durchgeführt werden?
Also es gibt zwei große Gruppen von Experimenten, die wir durchführen. Die einen sind psychologische Natur. Die gucken eben danach, wie verändert sich die Stimmung oder wie verändert sich der Schlaf im Laufe der Isolationsstudie. Und die andere Gruppe von Experimenten, die wir durchführen, sind medizinische Natur, in denen wir gucken, was sind die Auswirkungen von Isolation und Beringtheit auf das Immunsystem zum Beispiel oder auf das Hormonsystem oder auf das kardiovaskuläre System, also Herzkreislauf. Also die Experimente, die unsere Jungs durchführen, sind sehr vielfältig und zielen eben auf Psychologie und Medizin.
Aber die Experimente sind jetzt im eigentlichen Sinne genau die Experimente, um das Ergebnis von Mars500 selbst zu bestimmen. Es ist jetzt nicht so, wie ich vermute, beim richtigen Marsflug würde man ja unter Umständen auch auf dem Flug dahin richtige wissenschaftliche Experimente auch mitführen in Schwerelosigkeit. Sowas wird da jetzt nicht simuliert, dass man jetzt auch ein wissenschaftliches Experiment selbst noch bedient, was jetzt unabhängig ist von der eigentlichen Mars500-Simulation.
Ne, das gesamte wissenschaftliche Programm, das wir haben, ist ausgelegt auf den zukünftigen Marsflug. Das heißt, wir versuchen herauszufinden, was können wir tun, um die Mannschaft bei Laune zu halten, um sie motiviert zu halten durch so einen langen Flug. Wie können wir sie gesund halten, wie können wir sie fit halten, was können wir ihnen geben oder was können die Jungs tun, um stark und motiviert zu bleiben. Das sind so die Hauptziele unseres wissenschaftlichen Programms.
Mars500 hat angefangen im Juni 2010, ist jetzt auch bald vorbei, zum Zeitpunkt unseres Gesprächs Ende Oktober, also jetzt Anfang November, ist es dann auch fertig.
Genau.
Also es ist jetzt für die Teilnehmer noch nicht alles beendet, wie wir jetzt gerade gehört haben, aber zumindest ist die eigentliche Flugphase abgeschlossen. Das heißt, man kann zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt auch schon auf die ersten Ergebnisse blicken. Oder ist das noch zu früh, um wirklich von einer Auswertung zu sprechen?
Wir haben bisher noch keine detaillierten Ergebnisse bekommen von unseren Wissenschaftlern. Was wir aber sagen können, ist, dass die Mannschaft, die wir ausgesucht haben, sehr gut miteinander harmoniert. Es kam eigentlich nie zu größeren Konflikten. Und schon allein die Tatsache, dass wir uns heute eine Woche vor Studienende befinden, mit einer noch vollständigen Mannschaft von sechs Leuten, stimmt uns eigentlich sehr positiv und macht uns sehr stolz. Wir wussten natürlich am Anfang der Studie nicht, ob wir jetzt tatsächlich auf die richtigen Persönlichkeitsmerkmale geachtet haben bei unserer Kandidatenauswahl. Ob wir tatsächlich die richtige Mannschaft zusammengestellt haben. Aber es scheint so auszusehen, wie wenn das alles doch ganz gut aussieht.
Also es sind noch alle sechs da. Natürlich hätte jetzt jeder jederzeit sagen können, so habe ich mir das aber nicht vorgestellt und ich will nach Hause. Mach mal die Tür auf. Da hätte man natürlich die auch sofort gehen lassen müssen.
Aus ethischen Gründen haben wir immer gesagt, die können ohne, jedes Crew-Mitglied kann ohne Angabe von Gründen das Experiment verlassen.
Die müssen dann nur ein Zauberwort sagen und dann geht die Tür auf. Dazu ist es aber nicht gekommen, das heißt in der Woche werden dann alle quasi landen. Wie detailliert ist denn jetzt diese ganze Flugphasen-Simulation? Also wenn man jetzt zum Mars fliegt, dann hat man natürlich erstmal die Startphase, aber umso weiter man dann von der Erde weg ist, verzögert das ja dann auch zum Beispiel die Kommunikation. Solche Sachen sind damit drin.
Die Studie begann so, dass die Mannschaft sich 240 Tage lang auf dem Hinflug zum Mars befand. Nach ungefähr sechs bis acht Wochen haben wir dann angefangen, eine Kommunikationsverzögerung einzubauen. Diese Verzögerung wurde länger, je weiter sie weg von der Erde geflogen sind. Kurz bevor sie auf dem Mars gelandet sind, betrug die Kommunikationsverzögerung 20 Minuten pro Weg. Das heißt, es hat 40 Minuten gedauert, bis die Jungs dann eine Antwort von uns bekommen haben. Dann war es so, dass sie sich 30 Tage auf dem Mars befunden haben. Die wurden in zwei Gruppen geteilt. Eine Gruppe von drei Leuten ist um den Mars gekreist, die anderen drei sind auf dem Mars gewesen und haben dann sogenannte Spacewalks durchgeführt. Die letzten 250 Tage bestanden darin, zurückzufliegen zur Erde. Seitdem, seit sie eben auf dem Rückflug sind, wurde die Kommunikationsverzögerung auch immer kürzer. Unsere Jungs sind seit ungefähr einem Monat in einem Zustand, wo sie mit uns ohne Verzögerung widersprechen können.
Und was hat da so für Auswirkungen, so eine verzögerte Kommunikation?
Man muss hinzufügen, dass natürlich die Mannschaft nicht einfach so zum Telefon greifen konnte und ihre Freunde oder Verwandte anrufen konnten. Also Kommunikation war immer limitiert. Und eigentlich für mehr als ein Jahr war es so, dass sie nur Kontakt hatten zu uns, also zu Mission Control, zum Kontrollzentrum von Mars500. Und nur indirekt zu ihren Verwandten über Briefe, über E-Mail.
Das hat sich dann aber geändert.
Das war am Anfang der Studie anders. Da konnten sie noch relativ frei mit ihren Freunden und Verwandten telefonieren und sprechen. Das ist jetzt seit ungefähr vier Wochen auch wieder so. Und dazwischen war es in der Tat so, dass unsere Gespräche etwas anders waren. Die meisten Gespräche liefen dann so ab, dass zum Beispiel wir eine Videobotschaft aufgenommen haben, mit Fragen zum Beispiel oder mit Nachrichten von ihren Familien und Freunden. Die haben wir dann zu den Jungs geschickt. Die haben sie dann 20 Minuten später bekommen. Die ihrerseits haben dann eine Videobotschaft zu uns geschickt, indem sie auf unsere Botschaft eingegangen sind, indem sie noch erwähnt haben, was ihnen sonst noch so auf dem Herzen liegt und haben dann diese Videobotschaft an uns geschickt. Dieser Austausch fand ungefähr zweimal pro Tag statt. Also nicht öfter. Das heißt, ein richtiges Gespräch kam eigentlich fast ein Jahr lang nicht zustande. Aber es ging eben doch auch. Außerdem hatten wir natürlich auch Kontakt über E-Mail, indem wir uns relativ normal austauschen konnten. Man musste natürlich immer die Verzögerung. Nein, das ging alles über die Kontrollstation.
Und so wäre das auch beim richtigen Flug?
Genau. So läuft es auch zum Beispiel mit den Astronauten auf der Internationalen Raubstation.
Was mich interessieren würde, die sechs Leute, haben die denn alle jetzt so einen vergleichbaren familiären Hintergrund? Also ist das da auch, wie gemischt ist das? Wie viele haben davon eine Familie? Wie viele sind so alleinstehend?
Die Mannschaft ist zwischen 30 und 40 Jahren, grob gesagt. Einige von ihnen sind verheiratet, einige nicht. Einige sind in Beziehungen, andere nicht. Also es ist relativ gemischt.
Aber macht schon einen Unterschied aus, ob die jetzt verheiratet sind oder alleinstehend?
Bei unserer Mannschaft haben wir bisher noch keine Unterschiede feststellen können. Das ist natürlich immer sehr gut, wenn die Mitglieder, egal ob sie jetzt verheiratet sind oder nicht, ein festes soziales Netzwerk haben, das sie auffängt und das sie auch in ihrem Unternehmen unterstützt. Darauf haben wir auch geachtet bei der Auswahl. Mars500 hat gezeigt, dass es eben auch wirklich wichtig ist.
Vielleicht kann man mal so ein bisschen mehr so in diesen tatsächlichen Ablauf reingehen. Also irgendwann gab es halt den Start im Juni 2010. Gut, dass mit der Kommunikation, den Teil, den haben wir jetzt schon mit eingerechnet. Also umso weiter weg, umso schwieriger wird die Kommunikation, so verzögert und sperrlicher wird die Kommunikation. Aber ansonsten läuft es vermutlich vergleichbar zu einer Mission jetzt wie auf der ISS. Das heißt, es gibt dann ganz klar vorgegebenen Tagesplan, an den sich die Astronauten mehr oder weniger zu halten haben, mit Freizeiten und eben auch mit klaren Experimentphasen und Trainingsphasen. Wie ist denn das so angelaufen? Also lief das dann gleich von Anfang an rund und so wie man sich das so gedacht hat? Oder brauchte das erstmal seine Zeit? Gab es da in der Anfangsphase Schwierigkeiten?
Also ich möchte vorschicken, dass grob der grobe Tagesablauf von jedem Crewmitglied so aussieht, dass acht Stunden gearbeitet wird, acht Stunden Freizeit und acht Stunden geschlafen wird.
So grob.
Dann war es so, dass die Crew bevor sie sich in Isolation begeben hat, schon vier bis sechs Monate trainiert hat auf ihren Einsatz. Das heißt, sie kannten die Module, sie wussten, welche Gerätschaften sie für welche wissenschaftlichen Experimente sie benutzen müssen. Das heißt, am Anfang, als die Studie begann, war nicht alles neu für die. Natürlich mussten sie sich erstmal an alles gewöhnen. Sie konnten abends nicht nach Hause gehen und alles mit ihren Freunden besprechen, sondern waren eben auf sich gestellt. Die ersten drei Monate bestanden dann auch in der Tat darin, sich daran zu gewöhnen. Das war auch alles sehr spannend. Dann kam es zu einer Phase, wo sie das alles kannten. Sie hatten ihren Tagesablauf, sie wussten, was sie wann zu tun haben. Deswegen kam es dann auch so ein bisschen zu Monotonie. Damit hatten wir aber gerechnet. Diese Phase der Monotonie haben wir dann gelegentlich unterbrochen. Dann hat aber auch schon die Phase begonnen, wo sie sich vorbereitet haben auf ihren Anflug oder ihren Aufenthalt zu Mars. Das war dann alles nochmal neu, nochmal spannend. Da haben sie dann auch mehr gearbeitet als ihre acht Stunden und haben auch mehr gemacht als nur die wissenschaftlichen Experimente durchgeführt. Dann waren sie eben auf dem Mars, da war es nochmal alles anders. Sie haben nicht nur acht Stunden gearbeitet und konnten acht Stunden schlafen, sondern mussten eben ein bisschen mehr machen, mussten sich auch ein bisschen mehr vorbereiten auf ihre Spacewalks. Und seit sie den Mars aber verlassen haben, ist es in der Tat wieder so, dass sie einen relativ klar strukturierten Tag haben von acht Stunden Arbeit, acht Stunden schlafen, acht Stunden Freizeit. Jetzt die letzten vier Wochen sind wieder so, dass sie sich auf ihre Rückkehr auf die Erde vorbereiten müssen. Da sind dann wieder mehr Aktivitäten angesetzt. Aber ja, so kann man im Groben...
Aber es waren nur drei wirklich auf dem Mars?
Korrekt, die anderen drei sind drum herum geflogen.
Das heißt, die hatten eigentlich gar keinen Spaß, die sind da so...
Die hatten ihren eigenen Spaß. Die anderen drei, die auf dem Mars waren, die unterstützen, die haben ihnen sagen können, was sie wann machen müssen auf dem Spacewalk. Die konnten ihnen sagen, wo sie sich gerade befinden auf dem Mars. Also denen war auch nicht langweilig.
Okay, aber wie hat man die denn ausgewählt, die dann wirklich auf den Mars durften und wenn nicht? Ich meine, wenn man so eine lange Reise antritt, auf einen anderen Planeten, dann will man doch da auch mal den Fuß draufsetzen.
Es war so, dass eigentlich schon vor der Studie grob feststand, wer auf dem Mars landet und wer nicht. Das hatte auch was mit dem Hintergrund der Mitglieder zu tun. Die drei, die dann tatsächlich auf dem Mars waren, sind so Leute, die wir auch in echt auf dem Mars schicken würden. Das heißt, es sind Leute, die schon Erfahrung hatten, zum Beispiel im Probenaussetzen auf dem Mars oder auf der simulierten Mars-Oberfläche oder im Analysieren von Gesteinen zum Beispiel.
Also Leute mit wissenschaftlichem Hintergrund jetzt?
Genau, wären die anderen drei eher die Piloten und Ingenieure, die aus dem Raum geflogen sind.
Das heißt, die wussten das ganz genau, das wurde jetzt nicht erst kurz vorher ausgewürfelt und damit waren die auch zufrieden, die wussten irgendwie ja, selbst wenn ich zum Mars fliege. Ich meine, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn man jetzt so eine richtige Mission hat, bei den Mondflügen war es ja auch ähnlich, dass eigentlich immer einer wusste, ja ich bleibe oben und die anderen machen da jetzt ihre Sprung-Experimente. Ich meine, hat natürlich immer noch alles, man war immerhin noch mal beim Mond, aber man möchte ja dann vielleicht eben auch diese letzten Meter machen. Ich könnte mir nur vorstellen, dass das auch noch mal so eine psychologische Belastung aufbringt, die sich dann aber erst in dem Moment, egal wie sehr man sich darauf vorbereitet hat, dass man sagt, jetzt wäre ich aber dann doch gerne da. So was gab es nicht?
Nee, es hat natürlich auch Auswirkungen gehabt auf die Kuh, davon gehe ich fest aus. Und genaues werden wir dann nach der Studie erfahren, wenn dann die psychologischen Fragebögen und die unserer Psychologen zum Zuge gekommen sind. Aber bisher sieht es so aus, wie wenn jeder mit seiner Rolle zufrieden war und ist.
Was weiß man denn eigentlich so generell über Menschen in Isolation? Also ich könnte mir ja auch vorstellen, dass selbst wenn man sich jetzt so bewusst daran teilnimmt, dass man vielleicht irgendwann anfängt, so ein Kokon um sich herum zu ziehen, dass man bei allem Interesse und auch bei der Zielsetzung der ganzen Mission nach psychologischer Auswertung, dass man dann irgendwie sagt so, nee, ich brauche jetzt aber hier so meine Schutzmauer und ich lasse euch jetzt einfach gar nicht so rein in mein Hirn. Ich habe schon genug damit zu kämpfen, hier zu sein. Sind das so Aspekte, die da auch mit aufkommen?
Ja, wir wissen von früheren Studien und wir wissen auch von zum Beispiel Leuten, die auf Ölplattformen arbeiten oder in U-Booten arbeiten, die ja auch sehr lange isoliert und eingeschlossen sind, dass die sich verändern, dass diese Isolation auswuchern hat auf die einzelnen Mitglieder, aber auch auf die Mitglieder als Gruppe. Das wissen wir und das ist auch eine Sache, die wir beforschen möchten, objektiv und gezielt in Mars500. Wir wissen, dass sich während solcher Isolationen oft das Gesprächsverhalten verändert, sowohl innerhalb der Gruppe als auch nach außen. Dass diejenigen, die isoliert sind, oft das Gefühl haben, dass die Kollegen vom Kontrollzentrum sich nicht genug in ihre Lage versetzen, nicht genug empathisch sind, nicht genug Sympathie für die Situation, in der sie sich befinden, aufbringen. Das ist eine Sache, die wir untersuchen in Mars500. Und wir wissen auch, wir haben schon früher gesehen, dass sich Werte ändern. Das heißt zum Beispiel ganz konkret, ich mache zum Beispiel mal bei Mars500 mit und ich habe eine ganz bestimmte Einstellung zu bestimmten Themen. Jetzt bin ich aber 520 Tage mit fünf anderen Kollegen eingesperrt, die ihre eigenen Einstellungen haben. Und man kann davon ausgehen, dass ich im normalen Leben meine Einstellung behalten würde. Durch diese spezielle Situation, in der ich mich aber in Mars500 befinden würde, verändern sich meine Werte, meine Einstellungen. Das ist eine ganz interessante Entwicklung, die man zum Beispiel in den U-Booten schon gefunden hat und die jetzt ein wissenschaftliches Team aus Norwegen nochmal ganz konkret beleuchtet.
Es ist wichtig, wie man mit dem Team kommuniziert. Es gibt ja auch noch die andere Seite des Mikrofons. Es gibt ja die Leute, die die zugewiesenen Betreuer sind. Das ist ja dann auch eine feste Crew. Es gibt ja gar nicht nur die Crew innerhalb der Module, sondern genauso gut auch die Leute, mit denen sie regelmäßig kommunizieren. Weil die kann man ja nicht jeden Tag austauschen. Die müssen ja da eine psychologische Bindung aufbauen, quasi ihre Freunde auf der Erde, die auch so das Gefühl haben, dass sie dann eben auch von denen nicht fallen gelassen werden. Ich glaube, wir hatten hier in der Diskussion mit Reinhold Ewald über ISS kamen schon ähnliche Aspekte auch zur Sprache, wie wichtig das doch ist, dass man eben im Kontrollzentrum das macht. Das heißt, sind dann auch die Leute auf der anderen Seite auch Teil des Experiments quasi?
Interessant, dass du das fragst. Unsere Wissenschaftler haben sich natürlich für unsere Mars500-Teilnehmer schöne Experimente ausgedacht. Um diese Ergebnisse, die sie dann aber bekommen, zu verifizieren oder zu objektivieren, brauchen sie Kontrollmessungen. Der ursprüngliche Plan war, dass tatsächlich die Leute, die im Kontrollzentrum sind, genau dieselben Experimente durchführen, wie die Jungs, die in Mars500 sind. Das hat aber leider aus logistischen Gründen nicht funktioniert.
Weil die nicht genug Zeit haben?
Wir kamen zu spät auf diese Idee. Unsere Wissenschaftler haben das jetzt aber so gemacht, wie sie es eigentlich auch ursprünglich geplant haben. Die nehmen als Kontrollen die Leute aus ihren eigenen Labors zum Beispiel oder rekrutieren Studenten, die dann eben an ihren Experimenten teilnehmen. Aber für zukünftige Simulationen oder auch für zukünftige Missionen, auch nur zur ISS, werden wir es tatsächlich so machen, dass wir die Leute, die im Kontrollzentrum arbeiten und sitzen, dass die dann tatsächlich auch parallel dieselben Experimente machen, wie diejenigen, die in echt fliegen.
Also dieselben psychologischen Experimente, also medizinisch jetzt wahrscheinlich weniger.
Medizinisch kann man auch machen, weil, wie gesagt, Leute, die isoliert sind, bei denen verändern sich das Immunsystem, das Hormonsystem usw. Und es ist natürlich sehr schön, das dann mit einer Gruppe zu vergleichen, die an derselben Mission arbeitet, aber eben nicht isoliert ist.
Unter denselben Bedingungen ist, ah, verstehe. Weil man hat ja dann im Prinzip einen direkten Bezug auf Ereignisse, auf Aufgeregtheiten, die sich da ergeben, weil die sind natürlich dann auch allen bekannt. Ah, verstehe. Ja, so lernt man dann während der Mission. Das mag ja sicherlich nicht die einzige Lerneinheit gewesen sein, die da so kam. Gab es denn noch andere grundlegende Erkenntnisse? Oder so, hätten wir mal anders machen sollen? Ergebnisse, die so auf dem Weg dazu kamen?
Bisher läuft die Studie so gut, dass wir sagen, wir wollen im Nachhinein nichts anders machen. Womit wir aber zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht gerechnet haben, ist, dass sich die Jungs, um ihre Langeweile, um ihre Monotonie zu durchbrechen, dass sie sich ihrer eigenen Kreativität bedienen. Damit haben wir echt überhaupt nicht gerechnet. Und das ist sehr schön. Das haben wir bisher auch in anderen Studien noch nie so gesehen. Und zwar hat sich das zum Beispiel darin gezeigt, dass die Crew uns jeden Monat ein Gruppenfoto schickt, um uns und um ihren Freunden und Verwandten zu zeigen, dass sie noch leben, dass es ihnen gut geht. Dieses Gruppenfoto war in den ersten vier Monaten relativ langweilig. Also die standen eben vor der Kamera und hatten ihre Anzüge an und haben das Foto gemacht.
Wie man sich als Astronautenteam so fotografieren lässt, kennt man ja.
Dann haben sie aber angefangen, diese Gruppenfotos immer lustiger zu gestalten. Und zwar hat es angefangen, dass das erste lustige Gruppenfoto, das wir dann bekommen haben, da hatten sie sich dann verkleidet. Das war zu der Zeit von Halloween. Da haben sie wissenschaftliche Geräte und andere wissenschaftliche Sachen genommen, die sie eigentlich nicht nehmen durften, und haben sich mit denen verkleidet. Und das ist natürlich zum einen sehr lustig zu sehen, zum anderen hat uns auch gezeigt, dass es der Crew als ganzes gut geht und dass sie noch immer noch in der Lage sind, Späßchen zu machen. Dann haben sie um Weihnachten rum beschlossen, dass sie sich ihren eigenen Adventskalender basteln, aus den Sachen, die ihnen zur Verfügung standen. Sie haben auch aus alten Kartons ihren eigenen Weihnachtsbaum gebastelt und haben dann während der Winterfeiertage ich glaube viermal Feste gefeiert. Die haben einmal das westliche Weihnachtsfest gefeiert, dann das russische Weihnachtsfest, dann hatten sie das westliche Silvesterfest und hatten dann auch noch das chinesische Neujahrsfest.
Obwohl jetzt keine Chinesen mit dabei waren.
Doch, einer von denen ist eine Chinesin. Also denen geht's gut. Das hat man dann auch an diesen Gruppenfotos eben gesehen. Das letzte sehr lustige Gruppenfoto, was wir dann von ihnen bekommen haben, war im April. Da haben sie eine Fotomontage gemacht, in der alle sechs Crew-Mitglieder durch ein Modul geschwebt sind. Und es stand dann als Titel drunter, endlich haben wir die Erdanziehungskraft abgeschaltet. Das war dann ganz lustig. Diese Kreativität und dieser Ideenreichtum sind so Sachen, mit denen wir am Anfang nicht gerechnet haben. Und die der Crew aber irgendwie geholfen hat, über diese Zeit hinwegzukommen, also über diese lange Zeit der Isolation.
Nochmal so zur Klarstellung. Also das Ganze ist ja so ein bisschen Big Brother in Space, so, aber ist jetzt nicht so, dass da überall Kameras hängen und alles überwacht wird, oder doch?
Mars500 wird sehr gerne mit Big Brother verglichen, allerdings ist der große Unterschied von Mars500 zu Big Brother der, dass wir nicht auf Konflikte und auf Skandal raus sind. Im Gegenteil, wir sind froh und für uns ist das Experiment gelungen, wenn wir das relativ langweilig über die Bühne bekommen, ohne dass groß was passiert, ohne unvorhergesehene Ereignisse. Es ist aber so, dass die Crew sich ständig beobachtet wird. Überall in den Modulen sind Kameras befestigt, mit denen wir die Crew beobachten können und mit denen die Psychologen auch Gesten, Mimiken analysieren. Aber jeder dieser Crew-Mitglieder hat einen Rückzugsraum. In den Kabinen, die sie haben, sind keine Kameras. Die können sich doch jederzeit zurückziehen.
Wäre das auch auf einer richtigen Mission so?
Auf einer richtigen Mission wäre es wahrscheinlich so, dass keine Kameras an Bord wären. Also keine Überwachungskameras.
Weil man die Datenmenge gar nicht zur Verfügung hätte, das zu übertragen. Also das ist jetzt quasi nur, um einfach das besser beobachten zu können, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Aber das spekuliere nur ich persönlich.
Dann wissen wir natürlich nicht, was in 20 Jahren dann wirklich passiert. Aber zumindest ist es jetzt nicht so eine Anforderung mit, natürlich werden wir Videokameras dabei haben, deswegen müssen wir die auch in einer Simulation haben. Das mit den Gruppenfotos finde ich sehr interessant, jetzt auch in dem Kontext mit der Überwachung. Das heißt, sie wissen eigentlich schon, dass sie beobachtet werden. Und wenn die dann was Überraschendes machen, wissen sie ja eigentlich, dass sie in dem Moment dabei beobachtet werden, wie sie eine Überraschung, die ja dann irgendwie auch keine mehr ist oder zumindest nicht die selbe Auswirkung hat, wenn sie wissen, dass sie eh schon die ganze Zeit beobachtet werden. Oder haben die sich dann tatsächlich in diese unbeobachteten Bereiche zurückgezogen dafür?
Nein, sie wussten, dass sie von uns beobachtet werden, vom Kontrollzentrum. Aber ihre Freunde, ihre Verwandte und die ganze Öffentlichkeit, die auch an Mars500 interessiert ist, hat das eben nicht gesehen. Und ich glaube hauptsächlich für die außenstehende Welt, die Welt außerhalb des Kontrollzentrums, waren diese Gruppenfotos gedacht.
Natürlich auch für uns.
Wir waren die Hauptempfänger. Aber die Eltern, das weiß ich ganz genau, haben sich jeden Monat gefreut, noch ein Foto zu bekommen, noch ein Lebenszeichen zu bekommen.
Also bei dem Gruppenfoto war dann sozusagen diese Verstecktheit auch schon so mit dabei. Wenn man einen guten Witz macht, dann will man ja auch die Pointe nicht zu früh verraten. Auf der anderen Seite, also ich finde das wirklich ein sehr interessantes Beispiel, wo jetzt verschiedene Sachen auch mit reinkommen, die mir schon die ganze Zeit durch den Kopf gegangen sind. Also Isolation und so fiese Situationen, sag ich mal, in denen man sich auch so in seinem Leben befindet, kriegt man ja eigentlich am besten aufgelöst oder unter anderem zumindest gut aufgelöst mit Humor, mit Witz, auch mit so einer Leichtigkeit, die dann einfach alles Erträglich macht. Klar, wer lacht, dem geht es einfach besser. Inwiefern ist denn Humor und diese Lockerheit auch ein Teil der Kommunikationsstrategie mit dem Team? Ergibt sich das einfach so oder holt man sich dann auch mal einen Komiker mit rein, der dann so Animationen betreibt oder versucht man einfach grundsätzlich Leute zu finden, die einfach lustig drauf sind. Welche Rolle spielt das?
Also im Kontrollzentrum sitzen und saßen bisher Leute, die wir nicht speziell auf ihren Humor ausgesucht haben. Bei der Kandidatenauswahl für Mars500 war es dann aber schon auch so, dass wir darauf geachtet haben, dass wir einen schönen Mix haben aus, ich sag mal jetzt ein bisschen überzogen, Clowns. Und Leuten, die gerne zuschauen. Also wir haben einen Mix, einen schönen Mix denke ich auch, aus introvertierten und extrovertierten Teilnehmern. Und ich glaube gerade dieser Mix macht die jetzige Crew und auch die Crew von der 105-Tages-Studie so erfolgreich.
Ja, ich glaube 6 Extrovertierte in einem Raum, das würde explodieren. Und nur introvertierte, das geht auch nicht, ne? Was ist dann die goldene Mischung? Also von was braucht man mehr? Oder ist das einfach gleichmäßig verteilt?
Ich würde sagen, dass wir in der 520-Tages-Studie drei extrem, nicht übertrieben, aber drei schon extrovertierte Teilnehmer dabei haben. Einen der, oder zwei, die relativ normal sind oder ausgeglichen und einen, der ein bisschen introvertiert ist. Und dieser introvertierte, das sage ich jetzt aber nicht, ich möchte nicht, dass es negativ rüberkommt, diese introvertierte hat die Gabe, zwischen den Teammitgliedern, wenn es zu Problemen oder Konfliken kommt, zu Mediation zu betreiben.
Das ist wieder dieses typische S-Tech-Problem am Start. Das hatten wir schon mal beim Advanced Concept Team. Hier ist eine internationale Atmosphäre. Ich habe es auch gerade wieder in der Kantine mitbekommen, alle Sprachen sind zu hören. Aber vor allem, man kommuniziert auf Englisch. Und ich weiß schon, wenn ich dann hier mit meinen deutschen Fragen dann komme, dann kommt man schnell wieder aus der Spur.
Danke für das Zustehen.
Ja, natürlich ist das so. Ich dachte mir eben gerade noch, also diese Ausgeglichenheit, klar, man hat so Leute, die die Truppe dann auch in Wallungen bringen können, die Spaßmacher, die sich immer was einfallen lassen, die aber dann natürlich auch immer nur bis zu einem bestimmten Maße konsumierbar sind. Und wenn man davon zu viel bekommt, dann wird es halt auch wirklich zu viel. Auf der Gegenseite hat man die Leute, die so ein bisschen absorbieren von diesen ganzen übermäßigen Atmosphäre und die dann auch in der Lage sind, etwas wieder ein bisschen runterzutünchen und der Rest mag irgendwo so dazwischen liegen. Kann man schon gut vorstellen, dass es eben sehr wichtig ist, da die goldene Mischung zu finden, was jetzt die Gruppe so in sich betrifft. Was bei diesen Gruppenfotos mir jetzt auch noch mal so kommt, ist auch noch dadurch, dass sie sich jetzt auch an Geräten, die sie eigentlich gar nicht so verwenden dürften, vergangen haben und auch generell eigentlich so von so einer Erwartungshaltung abweichen, nehmen sie ja quasi so eine Auflösung der Disziplin auch in Kauf. Auf der einen Seite weiß man, ich bin jetzt hier auf so einem Flug und wenn irgendwas schief geht und das Flugzeug fliegt irgendwie am Mars vorbei und kriegt nicht den Schwung zurück zur Erde, dann werde ich auch meine Heimat nie wiedersehen. Also es ist für meine Existenz extrem wichtig, dass ich mich an die Protokolle halte und dass ich das mache. Auf der anderen Seite will aber der Geist dann auch sehr frei sein und will sich einfach freischütteln und sagen, ach, scheiß drauf, jetzt ist hier Karneval und wir machen jetzt hier Party und da wird jetzt hier auch mal etwas zweckinfremdet. Das scheint mir auch sehr, sehr wichtig zu sein.
Absolut, das ist sehr wichtig. Die Crew wusste auch ganz genau, die befinden sich auf einer einmaligen Mission. Diese Art von Studie gab es bisher noch nie und die Ergebnisse, die sie sammeln, sind sehr wichtig für zukünftige Simulationen, aber auch für den zukünftigen echten Flug zu Mars. Sie wussten aber auch, und wir haben denen das auch immer wieder gesagt, sie sollen Spaß bei ihrer Mission haben. Das bedeutet jetzt nicht, dass sie diese Mission ins Ulkige ziehen oder in Gefahr bringen, oder in Gefahr bringen sogar, aber Spaß muss sein. Und dass sie auf eigene Initiative einen Weg gefunden haben, um Spaß zu haben, hat uns dann auch wieder Freude bereitet.
Jetzt ist ja so, man könnte ja eigentlich auch von der Planungsseite her Ähnliches machen, also Unvorbereitetes. Also alles ist durchgeplant, alles ist irgendwie immer so, wie man sich das denkt. Das heißt, die Erwartung ist ja eigentlich bei der Crew so, so wird es immer gehen, es sei denn wir machen den Unterschied. Auf der anderen Seite dachte ich mir gerade, hätte man ja auch schon gleich ein paar Weihnachtsgeschenke verstecken können. Ja, sodass man sagt ja, ach übrigens, hier gibt es auch noch etwas, was ihr nicht wisst. Macht doch mal da den Deckel auf und dreht an dem Schräubchen und guckt mal, was da ist. Gab es solche Elemente?
Das gab es. Also sie haben in der Tat Weihnachtsgeschenke bekommen. Die haben auch jeder zu ihrem Geburtstag ein Geschenk gefunden und abgesehen von Geschenken und den Feiertagen war es auch so, dass wir zwei unvorhergesehene Ereignisse simuliert haben. Wir haben Notfälle simuliert. Auf dem Hinflug war es so, dass sie auf dem Höhepunkt der Monotonie sozusagen sich damit auseinandersetzen mussten, dass wir so getan haben, wie wenn es bei ihnen brennt.
Auf dem Hinflug zum Mars.
Nach vier, zwischen vier und fünf Monaten waren sie eben sehr gelangweilt, weil sie dann eben alles kannten, aber sie waren eben noch nicht an genug Maß, um sich drauf vorzubereiten.
Und dann gab es einen Brand.
Da haben wir dann simuliert, dass es brennt bei ihnen. Das hat dann zu einem Ausfall von bestimmten Geräten geführt.
Wie simuliert man das? Also, sagt man jetzt einfach, es tut mal so, als ob es gebrannt hat oder brannte es da?
Nein, wir haben es so getan, wie wenn es außerhalb des Moduls gebrannt hat. Und es hat dann dazu geführt, dass bestimmte Gaswerte angestiegen sind. Und sie dachten dann auch wirklich, also sie wussten nicht, dass es eine Simulation ist, sie dachten, dass es wirklich der Fall ist, haben sich dann in ein bestimmtes Modul zurückgezogen, und dorthin gerettet, und haben dann von dort aus auch versucht, das betreffende Gerät wieder zu reparieren. Es hat auch alles funktioniert. Und nach der Simulation konnten wir ihnen sagen, das war alles nur gespielt, simuliert. Und ich muss zugeben, die waren uns dann auch drei Tage lang noch sauer.
Wirklich, aber die müssen doch, ich meine, da müssten die nicht davon ausgegangen sein, dass wenn es da draußen brennt, dass da einfach so jemand da steht, mit dem Feuerlöscher in der Hand, und das löscht.
Nee, wir hatten von Anfang an gesagt, dass wenn Probleme auftreten, dass die erstmal versuchen sollen, die alleine zu lösen, autonom, wie bei einer richtigen Mission. Und das war dann auch ihr Bestreben, und die haben das ja auch gut hinbekommen. Wäre es jetzt tatsächlich zu einer lebensbedrohlichen Situation gekommen, hätten wir ihnen das gesagt und hätten wir sie natürlich befreit. Das geht ja nicht anders.
Aber die haben das dann auch so mitgelaubt. Da muss man ja auch wirklich sehr überzeugend sein.
Ja, das wurde überzeugend rübergebracht und die sind auch echt gut mit der Situation umgegangen. In der zweiten Hälfte, wo sich dann die Mannschaft auf dem Rückflug befand, war es dann so, dass sie den Mars verlassen haben, waren natürlich noch ganz aufgeregt, dass sie eben dort waren, dass sie den Mars sehen konnten, dass sie den Mars besuchen durften. Da waren sie noch ganz aufgeregt. Aber dann, nach einer Weile, hat sich dann wieder so was wie Monophonie eingeschlichen. Und um das zu durchbrechen, haben wir dann wieder einen Notfall simuliert. Und diesmal haben wir das so gemacht, dass sie acht Tage lang von jeglicher Kommunikation abgeschnitten waren. Das heißt, sie haben acht Tage lang keine E-Mails bekommen, die hatten acht Tage lang keine Videobotschaften und hatten acht Tage lang einfach keine Nachricht davon aus. Sie wussten nicht, was passiert.
Aber man hat sie nach wie vor mit Bild und Ton beobachtet. Man konnte sozusagen direkt sehen, wie sie darauf reagiert haben.
Wir haben sie weiterhin beobachtet. Wir haben den Jungs aber in den Modulen gesagt, dass es zu einem Kommunikationsausfall kommt, weil wir durch einen sogenannten Kommunikationsschatten fliegen, wo der betreffende Satellit, der sie mit uns verbindet, eben ausfällt. Das heißt, die wussten...
Ach so, weil sich die Sonne dazwischen geschoben hat oder so was.
Genau. Die wussten also ungefähr zwölf Stunden davor, dass es zu diesem Ausfall kommt. Sie konnten dann per E-Mail oder per Videobotschaft ihren Freunden und Bekannten Bescheid geben, dass sie sich eben nicht umsonst Sorgen machen. Aber dann waren sie eben dann völlig abgeschnitten und auf sich allein gestellt während dieser acht Tage.
Und das heißt, es war so ein bisschen unvorhergesehen, aber unvorhergesehen mit Ansage. Aber zwölf Stunden ist ja eigentlich... Kommt mir jetzt so ein bisschen merkwürdig vor, weil ich meine, sowas würde man ja in einem richtigen Maßflug schon vorher wissen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass da auf einmal so wenigstens irgendwelche Planeten kommen und sich so dazwischen schieben, so Ohopala, den haben wir jetzt aber nicht gesehen. Das ist ja eigentlich alles Teil der Missionsplanung. Ist das dann schon mehr so eigentlich eine Art und Weise etwas anzukündigen, womit sie jetzt zwar so nicht gerechnet haben?
Genau, wir wollten das eben ein bisschen abmildern.
Genau, dass sie sich jetzt nicht einfach so komplett... Man schaltet jetzt einfach so mittendrin ab und dann ist es tot. Hätte man aber auch machen können.
Hätte man machen können, ja. Und ich muss auch sagen, um das Ganze ein bisschen realistisch zu machen, haben wir ihnen von vornherein nicht gesagt, für wie lange dieser Kommunikationsausfall ist. Sie wussten nicht, ob das jetzt ein Tag ist oder ob das ein ganzer Monat ist.
Sie hatten schon eine Ahnung, dass es länger als zehn Minuten ist?
Genau, das wussten sie. Und wir dachten eigentlich auch, dass diese Extremsituation oder dieser Notfall mehr Stress auslöst bei den Jungs. Sie sind aber relativ gelassen damit umgegangen und nach diesen acht Jahren Kommunikationsausfall haben sie uns auch gesagt, die haben sich gefühlt wie im Urlaub, weil sie von uns mal keine Nachricht bekommen haben und weil wir ihnen eben mal nicht auf die Finger geguckt haben und gesagt haben, das müsst ihr jetzt so und so machen.
Und hat sich dann die Disziplin dann auch so weiter erhalten mit regelmäßigen Trainings? Ist der Tagesablauf dann auch genauso fortgesetzt worden oder riss das schon so ein bisschen ein?
Nee, die waren dann noch trotzdem sehr diszipliniert, haben weiterhin ihre wissenschaftlichen Aufgaben durchgeführt, haben weiterhin zwei Stunden am Tag trainiert, haben auch weiterhin in ihre Tagebücher oder in ihre Videoblocks aufgezeichnet. Also da hat sich nicht viel verändert. Ja, das Einzige, was eben gefehlt war, waren die zwei Mal am Tag.
Ja, das hin und zurück.
Direkte Verbindung zu uns.
Das war denen dann egal, aber das hat wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen geholfen, dass sie sozusagen auf dem Rückflug sind und das große Ding ist schon passiert gewesen. Eigentlich verbessert sich die Situation von Minute zu Minute. Man kommt dem Planeten immer näher. Ich denke mal, so ein Kommunikationsausfall, keine Ahnung, eine Woche vor Ankunft, beim Mars hätte eine ganz andere Dimension gehabt. Fühlt man sich da nicht auch versucht, da so ein bisschen das Maximale rauszukitzeln und alle möglichen Störfälle zu simulieren, die man sich nur irgendwie vorstellen kann?
Ja, aber wir wollten es natürlich jetzt auch nicht übertreiben. Und irgendwann hätte selbst der noch so schön simulierte Notfall, der wäre durchschaut worden von den Jungs. Deswegen haben wir das eben bei.
Nach dem Motto schaltet mal das Mikrofon an, das ist jetzt nicht mehr lustig.
Genau und deswegen haben wir das eben bei diesen zwei Notfällen gelassen.
Du hast gesagt, es gab so Phasen, wo die Monotonie dann zunahm oder sogar ein Maximum erreicht hat. Wie misst man das? Woran macht man das fest? Ist das so ein Gefühl? Ist das die Art und Weise, wie die Kommunikation läuft? Ist das ein Ergebnis dieser psychologischen Tests?
In unserem Fall, im Fall von der 520-Tages-Studie war das relativ leicht zu sehen. Also als sie wirklich sich in der Hochphase der Monotonie befanden, konnte man die Jungs relativ schnell auf die Palme bringen, durch unüberlegte Kommentare, durch Antworten oder die haben uns oft über ihre E-Mails oder über ihre Videobotschaften um bestimmte Dinge gefragt, um Nachrichten von außen. Wenn wir die nicht schnell genug gebracht haben oder beschafft haben, diese Informationen oder das, was sie eben von uns wollten, wurden sie zu den Zeiten immer relativ schnell unwirsch. Und man sieht auch an den Nachrichten, die sie zu uns schicken, wie gut gelaunt sie gerade sind. Das hat jetzt nicht unbedingt was mit der Monotonie zum Beispiel zu tun, aber wenn wir zum Beispiel E-Mails von denen bekommen, wo keine Anrede drin ist, dann wissen wir, ok, heute ist kein so guter Tag für denjenigen. Wenn wir dann allerdings am nächsten Tag wieder ein E-Mail bekommen haben mit Hallo Jennifer oder Liebe Jennifer und dann eben das restliche E-Mail, dann wussten wir, ok, dann geht es gut oder besser. An solchen Kleinigkeiten konnte man das festmachen und machen wir das auch immer noch fest. Also das hat jetzt wie gesagt nicht unbedingt was mit dieser Monotonie zu tun oder mit diesen Phasen, wo es dann eben extrem langweilig oder extrem monoton war für die Jungs. Sondern dieses Muster zieht sich durch die ganze Studie.
Ich bin immer versucht, bei solchen Projekten meinen Lieblings-Science-Fiction 2001 immer wieder aus dem Schrank zu holen, der ja auch so einen elend langen Flug zum Jupiter in seinem dritten Teil dann thematisiert. Diese ganze Isolation und diese Stille des Weltraums und dieses abgeschnittenen Sein von der Erde finde ich immer sehr plastisch rüberbringend. Trotzdem war das ja ein Blick in die Zukunft aus den 60er Jahren heraus. Wenn man jetzt solche Projekte durchführt, diese Simulationen durchführt, was für ein Gefühl gewinnt man, wie tauglich der Mensch als Wesen für solche Herausforderungen eigentlich ist. Ist das besser als man denkt oder ist die Belastung enorm? Wie kann man das quantifizieren?
Ich würde sagen, dass der Mensch ideal ist für solche Missionen. Besser als zum Beispiel, das ist ja oft im Gespräch, es wird ja oft diskutiert, ob man nicht lieber Roboter auf solche Missionen schickt.
Was man ja auch schon gemacht hat.
Aber die Erfahrung zeigt doch immer wieder, dass Menschen verlässlicher sind, dass die auch flexibler sind, dass die mit unerwarteten Situationen sehr gut zurechtkommen, als zum Beispiel ein Roboter oder ein unbemanter Raumschiff. Und dass sie durchaus mit jedweder Belastung zurechtkommen können. Das hat Mars500 gezeigt und das haben auch alle anderen Missionen zu ISS oder zum Mond gezeigt.
Wenn der Humor stimmt und wenn die Motivation passt. Wie sehr ist denn auf dem Mars, in diesem Marsmodul, wie echt war das? War das auch kalt? War das stürmisch? Also wie viel Aufwand wurde da getrieben, um diese Mars-Situation da echt zu machen?
Es war nicht kalt, es war nicht stürmisch, aber der Untergrund war rot, also sie befanden sich auf dem roten Planet. Sie mussten Raumanzüge anziehen und mit diesen relativ großen und schweren Raumanzügen mussten sie ihre Aufgaben erledigen. Und auch die Aufgaben, die wir uns für die Jungs auf dem Mars ausgedacht haben, waren relativ realistisch. Das heißt, sie mussten Proben sammeln, sie mussten Sensoren auslegen, sie mussten mit einem Roboter in der Gegend rumfahren und die Gegend erkundschaften. Also auch das war sehr real.
So real, dass sie das auch selbst irgendwann geglaubt haben? Also weiß man, wie sehr sie das so verinnerlicht haben? Also trennt man sich nicht irgendwann von diesem Gedanken, dass man Teil einer Simulation ist und fängt dann einfach an zu glauben und richtig zu fühlen, dass man irgendwie unterwegs ist, auch wenn alle Anzeichen eigentlich dagegen sprechen?
Das ist eine der ersten Fragen, die ich unseren Jungs stellen werde, ob sie das, ab wann sie das so verinnerlicht haben. Ich glaube aber, dass sie immer wussten, dass es sich um eine Simulation handelt. Und auch in ihren Botschaften haben sie immer wieder rübergebracht, dass sie wissen, dass es sich um eine Simulation handelt, dass sie aber trotzdem immer sehr stolz sind, einen Schritt oder ihren Beitrag zu leisten für den dann hoffentlich wahren bemannten Flug zu Mars.
Unsere Jungs, höre ich immer, die emotionale Bindung an diese Truppe scheint auch enorm gewachsen zu sein über diese Zeit.
Klar, unsere Jungs liegen uns sehr am Herzen. Wir tun alles, um sie glücklich zu sehen, dass die Mission erfolgreich verläuft, dass es den Jungs aber auch selber gut geht und dass es auch ihren Familien und Freunden und ihrem Umfeld gut geht. Auch wenn die Studie zu Ende ist, werden wir mit ihnen in Kontakt bleiben und sie auch weiterhin betreuen.
Ist das schon so eine vergrößerte Familie, mit der man es auf einmal zu tun hat? Ich meine, wenn man auf täglicher Basis über Persönliches wahrscheinlich spricht bzw. sich die ganze Zeit um die Psyche Gedanken macht, auch mit diesen Freunden nämlich auch im Kontakt steht, zumindest zwischenzeitlich.
Das kann man durchaus so sagen. Und z.B. mit den Teilnehmern aus der 105-Tages-Studie stehe ich immer noch in gutem Kontakt und bin auch gut befreundet inzwischen mit ihnen.
Was sich bei 500 Tagen dann noch verfünffachen könnte, wenn das überhaupt möglich ist. Was steht denn jetzt als nächstes und letztes an, wenn jetzt wirklich die 520 Tage dann komplett gelaufen sind? Gehen die einfach raus und fahren nach Hause? Oder was machen die dann?
Nächste Woche ist eben die Studie zu Ende. Die 520 Tage der Isolation sind dann auch vorbei. Die Jungs werden dann aber erst mal noch in Moskau bleiben und dort noch mal Tests über sich ergehen lassen, damit wir die Ergebnisse mit den Daten von der Isolationsstudie selber vergleichen können. Anschließend werden wir natürlich die Daten analysieren und auch im circa dreimonatlichen Abstand sie immer wieder einbestellen und noch mal Messungen durchführen. Die Jungs werden dann auf eine Tour durch Europa geschickt, genau wie Astronauten das nach ihren jeweiligen Missionen auch machen, wo sie dann der Öffentlichkeit erzählen können, was ihre Erfahrungen waren von der Mission. Wenn das vorbei ist, werden wir sie dabei unterstützen, wieder Fuß zu fassen in der normalen Arbeitswelt.
Sind die eigentlich über die Veränderung auf dem Planeten in irgendeiner Form in Kenntnis gesetzt worden? Haben die auch die Nachrichtenlage vollständig mitgeschnitten?
Sie wurden täglich mit den für sie jeweils interessanten Nachrichten versorgt. Das heißt, wir haben ja einen Franzosen und einen Italiener von unserer Seite als Teilnehmer und der Franzose hat dann eben die Nachrichtnehmer aus Frankreich bekommen und der Italiener hat die Nachrichten, die in Italien gerade oben waren, bekommen.
Das heißt, so eine Zeitung oder so E-Mail mit Zusammenfassung?
Zeitungen haben sie nicht bekommen. Ich glaube auch, sie freuen sich auf ihre erste normale Zeitung. Aber sie haben E-Mails bekommen, wo eben die Ereignisse des jeweiligen Tages oder auch der Woche zusammengefasst wurden.
Okay, also sie stehen ja nicht so komplett vor einer veränderten Welt und es ist ja alles anders und wo ist denn dieses Land geblieben? Das war doch das letzte Mal noch da. Gut, also selbst in der Isolation und fernab des Planeten kann man dann noch quasi Teil der Gesellschaft bleiben. Und ich glaube, das ist dann auch am Ende der eigentliche Erfolg, wenn das gelingt, so ein Team, obwohl es so weit weg ist, das Gefühl zu geben, dass sie trotzdem irgendwie noch Teil von zu Hause sind.
Genau, wir haben sie nicht vergessen.
Ja, das wäre wahrscheinlich das Schlimmste. Insofern, ein erfolgreiches Projekt ist denn jetzt in irgendeiner Form etwas Ähnliches schon angedacht, dass so etwas fortgesetzt wird? Oder ist das jetzt erst mal das Material, mit dem man die nächsten zehn Jahre wieder bestreiten kann?
Wir werden sicherlich, bevor wir uns auf einen echten Flug zu Mars begeben, noch weitere solcher Studien durchführen müssen. Auch auf anderen Plattformen, wo wir die Effekte der Schwerelosigkeit oder auch der Weltraumstrahlung beforschen und untersuchen. Aber jetzt vorher sind wir wahrscheinlich mehr als genug damit beschäftigt, die Daten aus der 520-Tage-Studie zu analysieren.
Das ist jetzt die eigentliche Herausforderung der nächsten Zeit. Wie lange wird man damit beschäftigt sein?
Mindestens ein, zwei Jahre. Wir haben ja Daten aus mehr als 18 Monaten.
Ja, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Ja, wenn wir nichts ganz Dramatisches Wichtiges vergessen haben, haben wir was vergessen? Fehlt noch was? Dann sag ich vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zu Mars500, die Auswirkungen von Langzeitflügen, wie zum Beispiel zu Mars, herauszufinden, um dort neue Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen. Auch das ein wichtiger Teil der Raumfahrt, der hier auf dem Boden stattfindet. Vielen Dank für das Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. In zwei Wochen geht es wieder weiter. Ich sag Tschüss und bis bald.